the biggest creators in the world are at
the center of a scam and I don't know if
I should talk about it some have been
defrauded others are associated and most
are plain embarrassed but I don't want
to get sued I mean what do you think I
should do here have a drink and maybe
start at the beginning
thanks it started 2 months
ago hello this is coffeezilla I Know Who
You Are
and I've got something for you tell me
more all right well this is for sure a
lie there's no way you look that cool
okay maybe I exaggerated the setting a
bit but I did get a
[Music]
call hello coffeezilla I've got a scan
for you it's called Revolt huge
influencers lies people haven't been
paid how much how much are we talking
not sure rumors 5 mil and some of the
merchandise still hasn't shipped you
interested yeah can I Source you n keep
me Anonymous on this
one now this sounds more like the coffee
I know yeah yeah you're missing the
point after getting this call and
finishing my very important business I
started digging around but the same word
kept cropping up so you have heard of
Revolt can I put this on the record no
keep it anonymous all right this is
great info but how do you feel about
going public sorry keep my name out of
it keep me Anonymous please yeah I can
keep you Anonymous
sure I was hitting a wall and I was
getting
frustrated little by little though a
picture emerged not fully on the record
not fully off the voices of more than a
dozen anonymous calls complaining about
this one merch company Revolt run by a
guy named Ryan pente isn't he the guy
who runs The Misfits yeah the the
YouTuber group and believe me they'll be
involved later the point is I was
hearing about this merch company revolt
and everyone said in 2019 through 2021
it was extremely successful working with
everyone and of course in exchange for
this success Revolt was happy to take a
cut of each of these merch drops in fact
I obtained some of Revolt sales numbers
from 2021 showing how much only five of
their drops made 20 million in Revenue I
mean mindblowing numbers these creators
who I've hidden for privacy made $12
million Revolt for their cut should have
made $4
million now that is a mystery how do you
screw up such a business making so much
money that's what I wanted to find out
problem was no one would go public then
you have nothing right rumors innuendo
maybe but if no one will talk no that's
the thing that kills me about this story
most of the creators did talk employees
talked everyone behind the scenes they
couldn't stop talking this is why I'm
struggling with this story if it was
just off the Record I'd kill it if
everyone was on the record it's an easy
story right but it's it's neither I'm in
limbo well let's just get to what the
accusations are then anonymously I was
just getting to that as I was saying
Revolt made huge profits massive merch
drops but there was another side of
things Ryan pente had a spending problem
he took six private jet trips in a month
thousands of dollars every night on
dinner we have receipts for by the way
they spent 25,000 a week to rent a
mansion in LA and they rented a Ferrari
for $20,000 for a week but the thing was
it wasn't really Ryan footing the bill
it was actually Revolt right even as
this company's raking in money Handover
fist they were spending more than they
could afford which was brought up to
Ryan as a problem so why aren't you a
million
millionaire he spends money like
a did you always spend money like an
idiot yeah I've always spent money like
a I mean the thing with money is I like
to be able to provide that experience to
everybody so a lot of the money that I
spend is actually on other people for
the most part because I'm just like yeah
let's do it like let's have fun yikes so
they just spent it all is that it is
that the scam no no no you're getting
ahead of me look uh mind topping me off
sure sure it'll get you to spill the
beans so what
else well the spinning part was just the
start of it at this point Ryan's plan
was described to me by a source who knew
him as Creator a does a drop Ryan would
then spend a large chunk of that on
private jets noou Balenciaga and then
Creator B does a drop but Creator a
still owed money and so Ryan pays
Creator a with Creator B's money little
Ponzi is if you ask me but the key key
here is that this works as long as each
merch drop is bigger than the last you
can keep paying for everything but
Revolt was starting to have issues
according to former employees Revolt had
terrible Logistics experience which is
okay when you sell 400 units but when
you sell 40,000 in one day that's a
problem not only that Revolt is starting
to pull in bigger and bigger talent and
these influencers are demanding bigger
and bigger minimum guarantees Ryan
agrees but things aren't like before
some of those merch drops underperform
now owes money not just to minimum
guarantees but they also were counting
on these new merch drops to pay their
older clients so they start delaying
payments ah here we go that's right For
the First Time creators they start
actually posting about their experiences
not off the Record publicly honestly
it's actually a really nice t-shirt like
in a in like a chill way thank you we're
not going to talk about the company I
made it with because they stole stole
everything from me so okay like I get
their Bad Company can I can you put me
on their send list please just like for
everyone I'll take all their merch dude
I'm not I'm not sure anyone will ever
make much with them again after recently
it was finally happening big creators
had started to talk about Revolt Carl
Jacobs said they're the worst people
ever that just blatantly lie smos
founder Anthony Pia says Revolt still
hasn't paid me it's been months now I
should say for the record that he
eventually got his issue resolved but
underneath his post another Creator
posted neatu saying they haven't paid me
either now I called her and for the
first time in this case I got a breakr I
am Nikki nichu I'm a twitch streamer and
Revolt owes me
$300,000 that's so hard to hear that's
so unbelievable and it wasn't just her
not getting paid she explained that also
people who ordered from her some of them
didn't even get their order after
everything anything was shipped first of
all a lot of people in Europe didn't get
their didn't get their merch and I
messaged them about it and they said
yeah we'll look into it never did a lot
of my friends who bought merch never
received it to this date yes these
orders which were in 2022 yes have not
been sent out or received yes now as bad
as that sounds as I looked closer I
realized this was common really common
delays missing orders sometimes the
order would just be wrong like when they
sent out a pin collection but forgot the
pins now because of this an Insider at
Revolt told me that in December of 21
they had over a 100,000 customer support
tickets open for quality issues and
items not being shipped and that gets us
to the good
[Music]
part in a world where Common Sense takes
a backseat and physics is just a
suggestion comes a movie that punches
logic in the face are you ready for best
pizza of Life bring friends down to
pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch tired of watching low
effort content then come on down
[Music]
okay where were we um can I get another
drink actually yeah I'll pour you
another one thanks remember that Insider
document I showed you earlier yeah made
me want to sell merch what I didn't tell
you is that it was all part of a pitch
deck for Mr Beast see Ryan pente had met
Jimmy and he wanted to convince him to
work with Revolt so he creates this
pitch deck you've seen the other Creator
sales numbers but there were also ideas
for Mr beast in there like nfts you
could redeem for Merch and there were
also some Financial projections on their
first drop together Revolt claimed Mr
Beast would make $4 million across 3
years 50 million in annual profit
there's no way that's what I thought I
thought maybe the team was delusional
enough to think it was possible though
so I asked according to insiders at the
company they actually met Jimmy and
started discussing minimum guarantees
and how Revolt would 10x his merch
business over the next two years but
check this out this being possible was
openly discussed by the Revolt team oh
no they knew yeah and this is where
things go from bad to worse so Mr Beast
gets this minimum guarantee deal to do
his 100 million subscriber collection
with Revolt right but Revolt doesn't
sell like they claimed they would it
does revenue way below expected meaning
Revolt didn't hit their minimum
guarantee so what do they do well this
is where things dip into fraud right our
Insider says I assume this is when they
decided to increased cost of goods
meaning Revolt charged Mr Beast more for
every item of clothing than he was
actually paying for at the
factory that's a pretty huge accusation
where's the evidence my question exactly
I got sent this what exactly am I
looking at here what I just sent you is
the pricing sheet from the Chinese
Factory top left you can see the invoice
item says rvlt meaning Revolt mrb Mr
Beast there's unit order sizes and
prices
and what are these ink marks that's
where changes were made see somebody
wrote down next to the factory prices
new prices higher prices did you talk to
Mr Beast about this well nobody would
talk on the record but I confirmed that
Revolt charged higher prices to their
team like it says in Inc Revolt charged
more per item than they were actually
paying the Chinese factories according
to their own insiders who else did this
happen to that's the thing we don't know
I asked around and the closest I got was
an answer from a former employee this
person claims right as I was exiting the
business he started talking about that
the production manager said she could
get the factories to write whatever she
wanted on invoices so it's definitely
possible this happened more it's hard to
say what I do know is when the money ran
out it all fell apart what do you mean
well the merch business has a lot of
middlemen people who create the shirts
warehouses store it fulfillment
the thing is Ryan was running out of
money for all of
it what is
this Misfits merch company going under
earlier this year the Salvation Army ARC
Memphis received a donation of a 100
plus clothing items from Revolt Factory
the merge company this ranges from
Corpse husband hoodies to Swagger Soul
hoodies and other scuffed merch with
everything coming out about the Misfits
quietly shutting down it makes sense
that they were selling and donating old
star they donated it basically from what
I heard the storage fees weren't paid on
time to the Fulfillment center so they
donated People's Clothing to get rid of
it so not only are people not getting
their merch on time some of it is
literally randomly sitting on eBay
because Revolt didn't pay their bills on
time H I assume you reached out to Ryan
pente about all this though right yeah
multiple times and we might have talked
but he ghosted me when the next wave of
accusations came then I think it's time
to go public about this wait did you say
there's more
accusations I mean the thing with money
is I like to be able to provide that
experience to
everybody so a lot of the money that I
spend is actually on other people for
the most part because I'm just like yeah
let's do it like let's have fun you're a
psychopath actually or maybe a sociopath
whatever the difference is operational
you that is a character you have
[Music]
though welcome back to the $10 million
Studio I was investigating what I
thought was a case of financial fraud
but what happened next made it also a
case of YouTube's own version of Harvey
Weinstein and I don't mean to say that
to exaggerate the severity of the
accusations you're about to hear I do
say it to convey the seriousness
similarities and signal that the
following is disturbing now if that
sounds a little too graphic I understand
if you need to click off the video we
normally don't cover these types of
allegations however I felt that given we
found this halfway through the
investigation we couldn't ignore it see
it all started last year when there was
a serious allegation about Ryan pente
being a predator it was made by an
Insider at the Misfits the YouTubers
that Ryan managed and this guy went by
packet these allegations range from
being coerced into inappropriate acts
witnessing Ryan perv on his employees in
the shower breaking into client phones
to search for private photos take
advantage of men who he has given way
too much alcohol and drugs and a lot
more now when this accusation first came
out and at the start of me investigating
there wasn't much in the way of proof
the only thing verifiable was that Ryan
encouraged others to get trashed which
we know because the Misfits themselves
talked about it so so funny compared to
like now when this the norm like people
get up all the time yeah now he's just
the one encouraging everyone else to
yeah now besides this piece of evidence
there wasn't much else in the way of
corroborating evidence until October
when two more stories came out that had
very similar stories to the original and
I knew we had to take them very
seriously in one story a guy who was
between 18 and 19 was told by Ryan quote
he saw potential in me before being
assaulted in the shower the other guy
was in their early 20s and tells a story
of how he was invited to a party with
the Misfits a YouTuber group he liked
but in order to get in the house he was
forced to inhale a substance as a
condition of inry later extremely
intoxicated he was also assaulted by
Ryan pente in the shower now let me
remind you that these all are
allegations but let me also tell you
that four other people have come forward
who know Ryan and corroborated his
character one person says one day I'll
tell my Ryan P story but for now I'll
just say this this Rabbit Hole goes deep
this person has been abusing his power
and money for years the trail of victims
that follow this man is staggering
another says I've known Ryan since we
were 16 he was always a weird pervy dude
from the start Billy says Ryan P has
been a disgusting individual for years
personally I've seen him do very
questionable things yet another says
Ryan P is a master manipulator I I
myself was manipulated by him for far
too long but that's not all that's just
what's public behind the scenes I began
to receive much more one guy told me
Ryan offered to fly him out and give him
$5,000 to cover work he showed me
receipts of this payment from Ryan he
then told me I end up going and it's all
good for the first few hours but when I
went to the bathroom he followed me and
without going into detail assaulted me
when I clearly was extremely
uncomfortable now this story
specifically has a thread we're going to
follow because there's numerous
allegations Ryan would use money to coer
people into situations they wouldn't
otherwise do like paying this guy $5,000
to come over for work or more commonly
he'd pay creators who were struggling
for explicit photos of themselves people
sent me emails they'd get notifying them
of Twitter DMS from Ryan asking for
explicit photos along with accompanying
payments from Ryan the reason I'm
telling you about all this is not only
that it demonstrates this Behavior was
happening and provides a financial paper
trail but some of it dovetails into
fraud because as I started asking for
some of these financial documents I
found that Ryan would often not just pay
people from personal accounts he would
use business accounts to pay for these
things specifically The Misfits business
account remember that's the Beloved
YouTuber group people supported through
patreon merge through a podcast turns
out their Company accounts were being
used in part to pay for explicit photos
of some of the fans of the show I was
shown these payments and the question is
why even do this to write it off your
taxes no matter the reason this is like
some weird form of fraud it's not the
kind that I normally like to talk about
but who uses their business account for
this we also need to talk about what
happened in April of 2016 as well when
Ryan asked the fan can we get married
when she told him she was 16 he said
come back in 2 years which which would
be when she was 18 but one year later
Ryan reached back out saying this quote
I retweeted your selfie do I get nudes
she replies that's illegal he says quote
don't worry I ain't no snitch now I
asked the person who gave me these if
she thought he was joking at the time
she responded no I think it was legit
because it happened a lot on Snapchat
and he fully like tried to give me money
to do it now this once again
corroborates the creepy Behavior we've
seen from Ryan pente in the past so for
those of you who have been counting we
now have five independent accusations
some Anonymous some fully on the record
we have multiple forms of evidence
firsthand accounts DMS Payment
Processing receipts and we have four
independent character testimonies from
people who claim to know Ryan now as
always I've tried to reach out to Ryan
to get his side of the story seven times
over two months months and have gotten
nothing in the way of an explanation the
last I heard he was spotted at an
airport and we have no idea of his
whereabouts
since now this investigation has been
exhausting honestly both emotionally and
just to carry all the details in my
heads of all the accusations the
whistleblowers so I imagine for you it's
been kind of confusing as well so I want
to summarize this piece so we don't miss
anything there's really two sides to the
story we have Revolt the company and
misfits a Uber group in one Ryan is
basically accused of running a Ponzi
type merch company where he spent too
much money and needed bigger and bigger
merch drops to pay off debts and minimum
guarantees when that didn't work he
resorted to faking invoices to creators
like Mr Beast to increase cost of goods
while being so bad at Logistics that
even when creators got paid their fans
received their merch late the wrong
merch or no merch at all and
occasionally creators merch would just
get donated to charity so that's fun too
and that's just part one then you have
the Misfits where Ryan used his
proximity to fame and money to abuse a
series of guys and girls through a
pattern of grooming intoxication and
then assault usually involving a shower
somewhere the damage this man has done
is hard to calculate because it's not
just a financial number on a spreadsheet
people have stopped creating content
because of Ryan others have had mental
health breakdowns and it's Pastime we
warn people about them so no one else
gets hurt thank you for watching and
supporting through View subscribing
checking out the patreon I'm so indebted
to this community and I will see you in
[Music]